congratulations aman and daniella you
mentioned that thank you players never
made it this far do you think that your
success on the show has inspired other
nba players to want to come out and
compete on the show
i hope so um
i'm casting new partners as we speak
yeah i hope i hope it does though
lebron hit me up
next season dancing with the stars told
you you got to get kyrie calris mello
man good footwork guys with good
footwork man no iman you didn't only
make it to the finals but you're also
the first nba star to do so how does it
feel holding that title
the pressure on even more
i don't know i don't think i don't
really see pressure like that uh i i
kind of invite pressure uh
it makes for a better moment and
apparently we're the moment makers
but uh tyra gave us that name so um
i i think we just sort of lean on
uh
you know doing choreo that is
challenging i came on the show to take
on a challenge and this is something
that i've never done and uh you know
it's been a lot of fun the whole journey
through it so we're just gonna keep
rolling with that
daniella you seem really inspired by
iman and making you know your size
different
difference work what has it been like
this partnership and what has it really
meant to you guys
it's amazing when you have a human being
who comes to every rehearsal willing to
do better than the next so
i couldn't have asked for more as his
coach in terms of just
his
commitment no he got a commitment your
positive outlook on everything you do
everything is
important in positivity basically and it
could be worse no
you know
we could be running through screens but
we're dancing it's actually amazing to
see someone come into every fitting
loving their outfits
loving the music
loving the energy in the ballroom he
loves it and it makes me love doing my
job you know so it's it's crazy it's
been the best
we could have asked for taking the
wardrobe home
could you guys talk a little bit about
the unpredictability of this season it's
so we sort of people were doing really
well and then people went home so
how how has it been unpredictable as
being a part of it and watching all this
unfold around you
we just stuck to what we did best and
that was just having fun to be honest we
were just focused on having fun every
single performance and you never know
here
where it's going to take you you don't
know how far you're going to get in the
competition so to stress about it is
pointless so we literally have the time
of our life and
that has been working for us yeah i
think our biggest thing is to like
uh make people feel something when they
see the performance you know not
always sometimes we're not always the
most technical couple on the show
uh but
um
i think we we go for things that make
people feel and inspire people the next
day so as long as we can lean on that i
think we'll be good throughout the show
can you uh walk us through nailing that
last stun uh daniella we saw you almost
fell thank god you did where i didn't
almost fall
where it looks like you maybe he was
sweaty and you were like falling down
but you know can you walk us through how
many tries that took and if you guys
feel like you deserved a 40.
actually
that move was the least practice move
out of all four lifts or three lifts
um
it felt pretty good to be honest uh but
i don't know they had
you know nines are great too we'll take
a nine
take a nine over five any day
you guys are all set
thank you thank you